As well as this video about Season 6 Episode
1, we’ve got a new video out now about the
final episode of The Expanse, Season 6 Episode
6.
You can watch it now at the link below.
The final season of The Expanse has begun.
And Episode 1 is called Strange Dogs.
Cause Season 6 is mostly adapted from the
sixth Expanse book, Babylon’s Ashes.
But the season also adapts one of the Expanse
novellas, Strange Dogs.
So it begins with this girl Cara on the planet
Laconia.
Remember, last season, a bunch of rogue Martians
led by Admiral Duarte went to Laconia.
Cara is the daughter of some scientists who
came here years earlier.
Cara grew up here, so Laconia is her home.
She loves exploring, and frolicking with the
wildlife, like an extra-terrestrial Snow White.
She sees a strange dog lookin thing she’s
never seen before.
And she gives food to an alien bird.
In the book, she describes how she read a
story about a lady on Earth who feeds bread
to birds, so figured she could do the same
here.
But this isn’t Earth.
Human food isn’t compatible with alien biology
– so her food hurts the bird, to Cara’s
horror.
So Cara likes Laconia, but there’s a clash
between humanity and this alien world.
Strange Dogs is about the unexpected results
of humans and aliens interacting.
It’s also an immigration story, about a
kid growing up in a new place, reconciling
her family’s past with her future in her
new home.
We see alien structures on Laconia, just like
the ones on Ilus in Season 4.
And we see this mysterious thing in orbit,
above the planet.
We know the scientist Cortázar is studying
this thing, trying to control it, and he has
a protomolecule sample.
On the thing in orbit, we see the blue glow
of protomolecule.
In the past, messing with the protomolecule
and alien tech has been.. disastrous.
On Ilus, it almost blew up a whole planet.
In the Ring space it changed physics and killed
thousands.
On Eros, it consumed an entire moon and all
the humans on it.
But Cortázar and Duarte are determined to
harness this alien power.
What could possibly go wrong?
Marco Inaros, extremist leader of the Belter
Free Navy, continues to hit Earth with rocks,
causing apocalyptic destruction.
Millions are dead, the environment is devastated,
the home of humanity is broken.
In the book, we get a chapter with Anna, and
her wife and child on Earth, struggling to
survive under a sky dark with ash.
Many Belters celebrate Marco’s attack and
join his Free Navy.
They see it as justice that Earth is suffering,
because for a hundred years Belters have suffered
under Earth’s oppression.
This Belter activist guy is the same one we
saw on Ceres back in Season 1 Episode 1.
He protested against Earthers taking the water
and air from Belters.
He said in Season 1 that when a hail of stones
hits Earth, maybe then Earthers will understand
the suffering of the Belt.
Now, it’s the Earthers who don’t have
water and clean air, it’s Earthers who don’t
have a safe home – so he says now they know
what it’s like to be Belters.
We see that survivors of Pallas are vowing
revenge.
Cause Pallas is a Belter station that was
attacked by Earth last season.
Avasarala had argued they shouldn’t attack
Pallas because that would kill civilians and
turn more Belters against Earth.
They attacked Pallas anyway, and whaddaya
know, the survivors wants revenge.
Killing civilians made more terrorists.
Earth’s ships are defending the planet,
destroying most of the incoming rocks.
But for Avasarala, it’s not enough.
Marco’s Free Navy is growing stronger, while
Earth is dying.
The dust thrown up by the rock strikes blocks
the sun like a nuclear winter, killing plant
life, starving the planet.
Avasarala says that she never liked shooting
stars.
This calls back to Season 1, when she looked
up at shooting stars and said she worries
about people throwing rocks.
She was right to worry.
She mentions that they’re repurposing their
“atmospheric CO2 scrubbers” to try to
clean the atmosphere.
Maybe those CO2 scrubbers were originally
used to stop climate change on Earth.
Cause the backstory in The Expanse is that
global warming made the ice caps melt, and
sea levels rose – we see that Anchorage
is now an island, and the statue of liberty’s
almost got her feet wet.
It was the crisis of climate change that forced
the countries of Earth to unite under the
United Nations for governance.
And it looks like they mostly succeeded in
saving the Earth’s environment..
until now.
The journalist Monica demands answers and
leadership from Avasarala.
She highlights how dangerous it is that Marco
now controls the Ring space.
The Ring space and Medina Station are the
central hub that controls access to all thirteen
hundred Ring gates.
All of the colony worlds beyond those gates,
like Ilus, are now at the mercy of Marco.
Marco could be doing whatever he wants to
a thousand worlds, and Earth and Mars wouldn’t
even know.
Avasarala gets away from it all and enjoys
floating in zero gravity.
Usually Avasarala hates space – “I fucking
hate space” – but now she enjoys the weightlessness.
Avasarala always feels weighed down by the
responsibility of governing Earth, protecting
the billions of people on it, carrying the
planet like Atlas.
She works so hard, and still everyone blames
her for everything from riots in Kinshasa
to Marco’s control of distant space.
In the book, she fantasises about retiring
to “some alien ocean” where she won’t
feel “responsible for making the waves go
up and down”.
She’s still grieving her dead husband Arjun,
she’s beyond exhausted.
Avasarala hates her job.
And her sidekick Bobbie hates hers too.
But millions are dying.
Work needs doing, so they do it.
The Roci crew hunt down and destroy a Free
Navy ship.
This is “Day 187” of their mission, and
there’s a sense of exhaustion, and futility,
among the crew.
Amos suggests they should be getting paid
for this, saying they’re not soldiers, questioning
their purpose here.
The crew are still grieving the death of Alex,
they’re stressed and tense with each other.
How much longer can this war go on?
They find a drive on a rock intended to be
launched at Earth.
Holden goes to disable it, but it warms up
to fire, which could kill him.
Naomi tells him to run, but instead he bravely
stays and hits it til it breaks.
Which is the same strategy he used on this
coffee machine.
So Holden almost dies, and Naomi is upset.
The books talk about how stressful and painful
it is for her when Holden constantly throws
himself into danger – he plays the hero
and risks his life all the time so Naomi can
never feel that her partner is safe.
So Holden realises that he’s “kind of
an asshole” to do that to her.
He promises Naomi to be more careful for all
of them.
Is that a promise he can keep?
Clarissa Mao is on the Roci now.
She once killed a bunch of people, and tried
to kill Holden, but Amos made friends with
her and brought her on board.
Amos and Clarissa work together well.
She’s learned quickly to be a mechanic – she
mentions that she didn’t have much experience
with this stuff in her old life – she used
to spend more time planning fancy parties,
as we saw in a Season 3 flashback.
Naomi doesn’t like Clarissa, and gets angry
at Amos for bringing her.
‘Do you think you can do whatever you like
now’, she asks.
Amos used to be totally loyal and obedient
to Naomi, almost like he was her son – Miller
called him Naomi’s “200-pound, homicidal
kid”.
But now, Amos has grown up, and become more
independent from Naomi – and he’s got
his own homicidal follower now in Clarissa.
So Naomi is having trouble accepting this
new independent Amos.
With Clarissa on board and Alex dead, the
relationships on the Roci are changing, everything’s
uncertain.
Even Amos is questioning his place in the
crew.
Can this unlikely family stay together?
Holden discovers footage of the Laconian ship
the Barkeith being eaten by the mysterious
alien entities in the Ring.
Remember, we saw its destruction at the end
of last season.
Holden says this reminds him of this artefact
on Ilus, which was a weapon used by the entities
to destroy the Builders who made the Ring
billions of years ago.
So on top of their family fracturing, Earth
dying, Laconians having protomolecule, and
Naomi’s evil ex conquering space, they’ve
also got interdimensional genocidal aliens
to worry about.
Naomi figures out that Marco’s rocks are
being guided by a spotter ship called the
Azure Dragon.
If they can destroy it, they could reduce
the threat to Earth, and free up Earth’s
ships to go after Marco.
This could be the victory Earth desperately
needs against the Free Navy Belters.
But Naomi has mixed feelings.
She’s a Belter, these are her people they’re
fighting against.
Her son Filip is with the Free Navy.
Can she go to war against her own child?
Marco’s Free Navy takes over Ceres, the
biggest port in the Belt.
Back in Season 1 Episode 1, we learned that
Ceres is the gateway for “immense wealth
and resources” – but Ceres was controlled
by Earth, who exploited and oppressed the
Belters who lived there.
So OPA leader Anderson Dawes worked to make
Ceres politically independent – to make
it a home for Belters, run by Belters.
And he succeeded.
By Season 2, Dawes was running Ceres as an
OPA Belter station.
Through long, careful management the great
negotiator outlasted his status as a rebel
and become a respectable politician.
After Season 2, Dawes’ actor left the show.
But off-screen, Dawes continued to work, alongside
Fred Johnson, to make the OPA a legitimate
Belter government, in peace with Earth and
Mars.
The Earth government called him a “friend”.
But some Belter extremists hated Dawes for
collaborating with the enemy – they called
him welwala, a traitor to his people.
And now Marco has risen up on a wave of violent
extremism.
Last season he killed Fred Johnson, and now
he reveals he’s killed Dawes too.
Marco has wiped out the moderate centre of
the OPA, and made himself the only option
for leadership of the Belt.
In the books, Marco doesn’t kill Dawes.
Dawes joins Marco.
Dawes doesn’t like or trust Marco, but he
thinks that working with him and trying to
guide Marco will be best for the Belt in the
long run.
Though he pretty quickly realises that won’t
work.
Marco installs Sanjrani as administrator of
Ceres.
Sanjrani is a man in the books, but is non-binary
in the show.
And they’re trying to make a plan to grow
food for the Belt.
Cause most of humanity’s food came from
Earth – so by attacking the planet, Marco
has put billions at risk of starvation, including
the Belt.
Belt stations like Ganymede make food, and
the Free Navy’s also been stealing food
from the colony ships heading out to the Ring.
But it’s not enough.
Unless they can build a sustainable system
to feed the Belt fast, millions of Belters
will starve, along with those on Earth.
Marco may’ve freed the Belt.
But freedom isn’t worth much if you’re
dead.
Marco is not very interested in feeding his
people, and doesn’t really listen to Sanjrani.
Marco’s more interested in his personal
vendettas, wanting to hunt down Drummer and
Naomi.
Marco doesn’t really care about the Belt.
He cares about his own selfish desires and
ego.
Marco’s son Filip uses his status as the
great leader’s son to get sex.
Filip has a lot of complicated frustrated
feelings about his place in the world, his
parents, his need for intimacy, his guilt,
so maybe this is an emotional outlet for him.
Or maybe he just likes sex.
Filip acts rude and entitled, and he uses
people, just like his dad does.
Filip’s friend Yoan has a vest made of alligator
skin.
To him, it’s a trophy of victory to wear
a luxury item from the defeated Earth.
He says now that Earth’s environment is
broken, soon there won’t be any more of
this stuff – industry will collapse, animals
will go extinct.
This could be “the last leather vest out
of Earth”.
To Belters like Yoan and Filip that might
not mean much, they barely know what an alligator
is.
But to Earthers like, us, the cultural and
ecological death of Earth is a tragedy.
The Belters and the inners fail to see each
other’s perspective, and that’s what leads
to dehumanisation and atrocity.
Marco gives a speech about how Ceres will
be the capital of a new Belter nation.
This dream of a Belter nation was shared by
Naomi, Ashford, and Fred.
It’s a worthy goal, and Marco says all the
right things.
But Filip knows it’s bullshit.
Marco’s not really willing to do the work
of building a nation.
He’s not really the heroic leader he pretends
to be.
Filip does feel loyal to Marco, but he’s
increasingly full of doubts.
Filip and Yoan hang out with a couple of girls,
and brag about their victories with the Free
Navy.
But then Yoan brings up Filip’s role in
the attack on Earth.
Filip stole the stealth tech that coated the
rocks.
Filip killed the scientists who saw the rocks
coming.
Filip helped kill millions of people.
Last season, Naomi told Filip that one day
he will feel guilt for that atrocity, and
that he’ll realise that Marco has made him
a murderer.
Naomi’s words have had an impact on Filip,
so he leaves and wrestles with his feelings.
Rosenfeld tells Marco that Medina Station
is installing “Laconian pieces”.
We know Marco and Laconia made a deal that
Marco can rule the Sol system, and Duarte
can rule Laconia.
So now it looks like Laconia is also providing
some.. technological support for Medina.
Rosenfeld says they “need to reinforce the
abutments”.
So.. what are they building in there?
Filip tries to get involved, and says the
Free Navy must feed the Belt, but Marco and
Rosenfeld brush him off.
So again Filip is rejected by his father,
and feels he can’t help the Belt, so why
is he here?
What was all the fighting for?
Was Naomi right?
Filip doesn’t know how to handle all his
feelings, so he gets drunk and harasses a
bartender.
When Yoan turns up, Filip starts a fight with
him, and then shoots him dead in a stupid
drunk impulsive murder.
Filip has killed lots of people before.
But Yoan was his friend, killed at his hands.
Will Filip finally face the consequences of
his violence?
And how will Marco react?
In the book, Filip just shoots a security
guy at a club, and the guy doesn’t die.
So the show makes it much more dramatic by
having Filip kill a friend instead.
Drummer and her family are hunted by Marco’s
forces, after her betrayal of Marco last season.
She lures an enemy ship into a trap with her
ship the DeWalt, which she controls remotely
from her other ship the Tynan.
But Drummer’s partner Michio fucks up and
presses the wrong button, forcing Drummer
to blow up the DeWalt to destroy the enemy
ship.
So Drummer loses a ship, and all the supplies
on it, because of Michio’s mistake.
Michio is one of Drummer’s partners in her
polyamorous family.
But Michio isn’t a fighter, she isn’t
trained for war.
So Drummer decides to remove her from the
crew and leave her behind somewhere safe.
Last season, Drummer’s partner Serge was
killed, her partners Oksana and Bertold left.
Now Michio’s gone too.
How much more can Drummer lose to this war?
Season 6 of the Expanse is the result of five
seasons of buildup.
A century of tension and resentment and between
Earth and the Belt is coming to a climactic
resolution.
And everyone’s relationships are being pushed
to breaking point.
Can the families of the Roci crew, Drummer,
and Filip survive this conflict?
Can the inner planets and the Belt co-exist
without destroying each other?
And, most importantly, what’s up with the
weird space dogs?
There are five more episodes left of The Expanse.
We’ll release a video all about the finale
of The Expanse on the day the last episode
comes out.
Please subscribe to this channel, and give
it a comment and like.
Thank you to Amazon Prime Video UK for sponsoring
and making these videos possible.
Cheers.